la trisomie 21 est elle une maladie rare
comment peut-on aller vers plus
d'autonomie des malades
autant de questions abordées lors de ce
13e colloque sur la maladie cet
événement sert à faire un point sur
l'avancée de la recherche mais aussi
cassé est quelques codes et idées reçues
l'objectif c'est de réunir les personnes
qui travaillent autour de de la trisomie
pendant longtemps durant deux ou trois
jours ce fin que ils puissent échanger
déjà entre différentes informations les
objets et éventuellement nous allons
nous avons nous annoncer d'éventuelles
avancées sur leurs recherches pendant
ces trois jours à l'ufr des sciences de
la santé une vingtaine de spécialistes
se succèdent comme françois vialard
professeur à l'ulb est ce qu il dirige
l'unité de recherche gamètes
implantation gestation et dans le cadre
de l'opération la course des héros ses
recherches actuelles ont besoin de dons
nous avons aussi proposé un traitement
en fait un anténatal pour les individus
qui ont une trisomie 21
pour pour enfin les foetus 4 du 21 pour
pouvoir en fait espérer un jour contrer
les les effets délétères de cette
présente troisième chromosome 21 sur le
développement cérébral dont
l'amphithéâtre de l'ue vs qu associatif
parents de malades mais aussi personnes
atteintes de trisomie 21
joël 28 ans a tout récemment sorti son
autobiographie il est important pour lui
de parler de son parcours à la fin
important pour un sel et au pire qu'une
pas qu'on m'a vu en tout on te on ne
taille les combats que vous menez qui
n'ont pas été faciles
mon nouveau affrontés avec ce qu'elle
était ce colloque se déroule tous les
ans environ 60000 personnes vivent en
france avec une trisomie 21